with the crises that occurred in
Syria or even in Libya and which then
exposed the entire Mediterranean to
continuous crossings it was
necessary to review the entire system, it
was important to have a procedure that
was efficient and streamlined that did not
bureaucratically overload the
member states
we see timelines that are
quite clear, that is six months for the
recognition of the
international
protection wine.
reception centers
because basically they had to
wait months and months before being able to
know what their destiny was and then
legal representation is ensured for asylum seekers for all
phases
here we have been very keen to guarantee the
rights of the asylum seeker in terms
of  information in terms of guarantees
p  procedural in terms also of
recordings of interrogations,
member states have an enormous
responsibility because certainly the
position expressed by the speaker by
the European parliament is a first step